[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and it looks
like we have some footage of the entire
demo for the upcoming game Marvel's
Avengers the reaction to the game so far
has been mixed to say the least but this
first real look at it makes it seem
incredible and throughout this video
I'll be showing you the full demo
footage from San Diego comic-con and
giving my thoughts on it at the end this
goes through about 15 minutes of
gameplay and it covers every character
and yeah it just looks amazing now there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
don't want some of the big elements of
the game's demo room for you then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for clicking this video I
hope you enjoy it so sit back relax and
let's look at the footage from the game
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
so our thanks business got civilians
trapped behind barricades
understood stapling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
your turn
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
whew
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
just got confirmation huge on food was
hijacked
three times every Tony
those are important okay whatever
my fury I don't like this second one
wait
[Music]
that that thing is hit
[Music]
all right which one of you b-movie
actually shot at me
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
put away by human with my attention
[Music]
[Music]
everything's just peachy
nobody kind of happens
[Music]
go for a ride kappa someone's initiated
the security protocols the chimeras all
the pundits take it over smells like a
heist bring back negative
secure the bridge that was what this
can't get into the city your others
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] are dangerous to those weapons
were meant for the good guy
is that supposed to be a joke about the
time your heads in the game not sure
that seems like the reactors
malfunctioning I'm getting strange
readings of the monitors like we're
being totally heat-seeking the thing
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you see
[Music]
a veteran if you can hear me the convoy
is transferring a highly lethal sonic
disrupter bombs are enemies attended
detonated within the state
I repeat secure the aesthetic once
are you kidding me something you and I
loved those years ago
[Music]
is an entrance
[Music]
[Music]
we need to get that dead banner that
bomb goes off liquify everything within
a 10-mile radius
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so that's everything we have from
San Diego comic-con for the game and now
after the initial trailers released
there was quite a lot of backlash over
it but I actually think had a lot of
potential and after seeing it play out
with all of its gameplay needless to say
I think it looks outstanding this is
everything that I really want from an
Avengers game and throughout it really
feels like there's a massive sense of
momentum to the entire thing another
thing that it does beautifully is that
it nails all of the different nuances
between the characters everyone feels
like they have a completely different
skill set which I definitely think is
needed in a title like this Iron Man's
gameplay is a complete opposite to
Captain America's but overall they all
kind of gel together so well and make
you realize why the Avengers are such a
powerful team they have all the bases
covered and I think this demo really
showcases that and yeah I'm just very
very excited to see how it plays out if
we get a full game of this I think it'll
be amazing and I couldn't be happier
with the first look they finally found a
way to capture the spirit of the
Avengers and I really think that this is
gonna be a home run for Marvel obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
demo and if you're excited for the
upcoming game comment below and let me
know and if you enjoy this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my full breakdown of the deleted
scene from Avengers endgame that she'll
dannis killing all of the Avengers in
the past before going to 2023 to take on
the new team I'll also be covering all
of the big news from San Diego comic-con
so make sure you stay locked to the
channel for more amazing updates this is
a channel for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you
[Music]